People spend enormous amounts of time devoting themselves to completely made up
stories. That is almost all popular movies, popular books, television shows — they’re just made up.
And I became curious about what it is about fictional narratives…what attracts people?
So one aspect about fiction that lots of people speculated about is this
resolution of suspense. That what you want is to not know the outcome and you read
the story to find the outcome and that's
why people are very concerned about
spoilers. A huge majority of people think spoilers spoil things.
And you just don’t in the end have the data from your own life to answer that question. That is, you
never see a movie twice for the first time – once spoiled and once not spoiled.
And it essentially takes someone stepping back and constructing the proper experiment
to discover what it is the people actually like. So what we were curious about is does giving away the ending, ruin the experience?
We brought undergraduates into the lab and we gave them
short stories from various genres. For some we didn’t spoil them, we just said,
"Here’s a story, read it and at the end we’ll tell you how much you liked it." And for
others we spoiled it and we spoiled it as if inadvertently. We don’t want to say, “here’s a spoiler!”
because that already suggests
that we spoiled something. So we have
we have them read a tiny paragraph about the story that sort of accidentally gave away
You know…”In this the classic story where a wife kills her husband with
a leg of lamb.” And so you read it and don’t even realize quite that it’s spoiled but then
as you're reading the story, of course,  you know exactly what the ending is. And what we found
remarkably was that if you spoil stories, they actually enjoy them more.
Spoilers actually were enhancers. And lots of people, when this finding came out,
expressed skepticism (even sometimes
hostile skepticism) about it telling us
why we were wrong in all sorts of ways.
But really, if you think about it, when people who go see
"Romeo and Juliet" don't think, "don't tell
me how it ends!" That is almost everything
going seeing "Romeo and Juliet" knows that Romeo will dies and Juliet will die, it's a tragedy. In fact,
the prologue to the play largely tells
you this. And also as I point out the
skeptics, people watch these movies more than once happily and often with
increasing pleasure. So even a movie like "The Usual Suspects" where you think
that movie will be ruined if you know the
ending and I ask people, so the second
time you watched it did you like it? "Oh I
loved it the second time! Every time I
watch it I I like it more!" You think, like
but you know exactly what the ending
is. The point is really we're not
watching these things for the ending. If that were the case, you could save yourself a lot
of time, right, you would just say, "Oh it was the butler!" Wow, thanks, I don't have to read the novel.
Really you read fiction for the beauty
of the prose and the cleverness of the
construction and insights into human
nature. And maybe even knowing the ending
is useful because it allows you to focus
on these other parts. The same way if
you're driving up Highway 1 through Big
Sur. If you know the road really well you
can now go round and admire the view and the otters frolicking in the surf.
Whereas if you don't know what the road
is, you have to be focusing on that mundane
detail. The argument isn't that stories
shouldn't have plots. And in fact we tried
a variation where we put the spoiler
into the stories. We actually modified
these stories.
A little bit of hubris, going in and fixing
what John Updike wrote. And it turns out that we
didn't make them better. So if you write
a first paragraph as if it's part of
the story that gives away the plot,
people don't like the story more.
wWt they really want is to have the
story complete but then this extra
knowledge about it. And there's lots of
evidence that this fluent processing of
information is pleasurable. That some
familiarity with a work of art
enables you to enjoy it more.
So what do you think? Do you like reading spoilers? Let us know in the comments
below and be sure to click that
subscribe button